practiquemos un poco con las sumas de
series geométricas infinitas aquí
tenemos una serie y solo para
asegurarnos de que estamos trabajando
con una serie geométrica verifiquemos si
tenemos una razón común vamos a ver para
pasar del primer término al segundo
multiplicamos por un tercio y para pasar
al siguiente término volvemos a
multiplicar por un tercio y así
sucesivamente así que podemos reescribir
esta serie como 8 más 8 por un tercio
más 8 por un tercio al cuadrado y miren
en cada término multiplicamos por un
tercio entonces podemos escribir esto en
notación sigma esto es igual esto es
igual a la sumatoria
y podemos empezar en cero o en 1
dependiendo de como queramos hacerlo
vamos a decir que va desde acá igual a 0
hasta bueno como esta es una serie
infinita entonces podemos decir que va
hasta infinito y es la sumatoria de cuál
es la razón de nuestro primer término
cuál es nuestro primer término miren
nuestro primer término es 8 entonces
tenemos 8 por la razón común que es un
tercio elevado a la potencia acá pero
déjenme verificar que esto funcione
siempre hago esto para corroborar que
todo esté bien los invito a que hagan lo
mismo vamos a ver cuando acá es igual a
cero ese debe de ser nuestro primer
término entonces 8 por un tercio a la 0
sin duda es 8 y cuando acá es igual a 1
ese será nuestro segundo término que es
igual a 8 por un tercio
a la primera potencia que es lo que
tenemos aquí y cuando caes igualados eso
corresponde a este término entonces
todos estos términos describen lo mismo
y ahora que ya vimos que podemos
escribir una serie geométrica de
diferentes formas encontremos la suma
bueno anteriormente en otros vídeos
vimos que sí tenemos una sumatoria que
va desde acá igual a cero hasta infinito
y tenemos el primer término a por r
elevada a la potencia k suponiendo que
esto converge es decir suponiendo que el
valor absoluto de la razón común es
menor a 1 si eso ocurre esto será igual
a nuestro primer término a entre 1 menos
la razón común si todo esto es extraño
para ustedes los invito a que vean el
vídeo en el que deducimos la fórmula
para la suma de una serie geométrica
infinita
si aplicamos eso para este caso tenemos
que esto es igual a nuestro primer
término que es 88 entre 1 - 1 - la razón
común que es un tercio y sabemos que
estos y converge porque el valor
absoluto de la magnitud de la razón
común que es igual a un tercio sin duda
es menor a 1 así que esto es igual a 8
entre 1 menos un tercio que es igual a
dos tercios y esto es igual a 8 por 3
medios que es igual a vamos a ver si
dividimos 8 entre 2 nos queda 4 y esto
es igual a 12